hey guys welcome back to brand-new Vita
we're back on apex legends again damn
it's been a long time since I've said
that apex has been a little bit on the
down-low in terms of content and if
you've been playing the game you
completely understand what I mean
but the developers a EA and respawn have
basically given us a post on what we're
supposed to be expecting coming in the
future of this season and is well coming
in season two and want some stuff we're
gonna be seeing so I'll be showing some
images on screen as well as talking
about what can be expected and how this
may actually change apex and actually
did a lot of players back into the game
or maybe even you could come back to the
game because of it so as always like
today if you do enjoy subscribe for new
I'll cover the informational side of
apex legend so I cover all that stuff as
well as the lore so if you want to be
kept up-to-date with everything
happening within the world of apex
legends and never miss ever update
definitely stay subscribe to channel my
Twitter and discord will be in the
description down below if you guys when
I join that but be highly appreciated
and let's get started with today's post
so amidst all the news with the games
that I've been covering on the channel
like for honor that's going to be going
to e3 Call of Duty got a new [ __ ]
trailer today at 1 p.m.
apex legends is also gonna be getting
some spotlight which is why I want to
cover it and it's going to be coming out
what's happening with the legendary Hunt
s balsam details on the improvement of
the season to battle pass so first up is
the legendary hunt this is going to be I
assume happening within season one and
we're going to be getting some legendary
hunt challenges and you can earn some
new rewards such as a legendary blood
hound skin called the master of the hunt
as well as a legendary skin at four
Wraith and the are 301 and called the
legendary honored and the legendary
Knight tear respectively I'll be
flashing these images on screen first
we're gonna have the blood hound skin
it's gonna have your standard type of
style so none of these samurai looking
outfit your very basic bloodhound but
he's gonna have a lot of black and gold
and of course the Raven hasn't changed
any colors but the offer looks really
nice giving him really of that master of
the hunt feel definitely gonna be
wearing this as soon as I complete these
challenges and then here is the Wraith
skin she looks absolutely insane if you
know anything about for honor and you
know the character shaman she looks
exactly like this will be flashing up an
image on screen of what shaman looks
like from another game that I covered
for honor
she looks pretty much a very similar
like this as well so I cannot wait to
grab this I might actually have to play
Rathenau
seeing as this skin looks beautiful a
lot of bones everywhere a lot of face
paint
it looks like blonde hair and some type
of dreadlock form kind of tied up
because that looks like very dreadlock
type hair got a couple face paint
markings and some tattoos special and
the legs in the face and she also was
using her usual knife in the photo which
looks absolutely insane as well as the
r3l one which kind of gives this bone
feel got some white bones some red and
blue dye on the bones as well on your
are 301 judging from the iron sight it's
gonna look a very like the similar are
301 in terms of the iron sight very
standard except it's going to have that
bone feel so it's gonna look really cool
I have no clue what these challenges are
but we'll get into that a little bit in
a second they say we'll have more
details on the legendary hunt challenges
to share with you next week Tuesday but
for now get ready for the hunt so just
be keeping out on the channel next
Tuesday I'll be trying to cover what
those hunt challenges are and then even
so I might even also make a video on how
to get them the fastest because of
course everyone wants to get these
really cool skins because Wraith and
bloodhound are one of the more popular
characters in the game and seeing as
there's a lot of people and these skins
are really cool of course people want to
get those there's no details yet as if
there's going to be any other outfits
for Pathfinder costaq players did you
brought their players etc but that might
come later in the future this might be
the first iteration of the legendary
hunt challenges for the week and the
week after that we might get a couple
more characters I hope so because they
have a track record of giving skins for
characters but only a small amount maybe
two or three and then the rest of the
cast gets nothing so let's hope they
actually follow through and give the
skins for everybody on top of that they
have details on the season to battle
pass on June 8th on Saturday and I
believe around 1:00 p.m. they're gonna
be showing off the season to battle pass
and possibly the new character if there
is going to be one I would assume there
will be and they're also going to be
sneak picking up some high-level
improvements in this little post that
they said and to give you a little bit
of a tldr of what's going to be
happening with these upcoming
improvements there will be daily and
weekly challenges for the battle paths
to allow you to rank up easier and just
give you a lot more XP the time to get
to level 100 will be significantly
reduced because it is really a pain to
get to want level 100 it's not
incredibly hard but with the rewards
that we were given in the battle past
that really won't work the grind of
putting 3040 hundred hours into the
battle fast just to get those skins they
also added a lot more legendary skins
into the game
for the reward track which is nice and
they will be replacing the badge and
stat tracker rewards but adding three
new areas of content this could be more
weapon skins more legendary skins or
something entirely different but yet the
badges and the stat track rewards are
going to be going a lot of people
complain that those were in there so I'm
glad that those are going to be taken
out and you're gonna be earning enough
crafting material rewards for an entire
legendary item at the end of the battle
password to whatever your heart's desire
one thing that's actually really
interesting is that loot boxes have been
getting a lot of hate with like the apex
packs that the apex legends has and the
overwatch through boxes so certain
companies have actually banned that
because that counts as underage gambling
for care you know for people that are
1819 and aren't actually old enough to
gamble so they basically have taken it
out in certain countries I believe
Germany is one of those countries in
Europe and if on the season one battle
passed I remember seeing this on reddit
in the very beginning they actually
didn't get apex coins during the battle
past they actually got crafting
materials so they were able to get a
full legendary skin at the beginning of
the season pass so now not just them but
everyone now will be able to get if you
get from level 0 to level 100 you will
have enough crafting materials to get
yourself a really cool legendary skin
for the character you want or a banner
pose or whatever you want to get all
that stuff is going to be accessible as
long as you beat the entire season to
battle pass and which is really nice and
I'm not really sure why they didn't do
this in the first place going off of the
daily and weekly challenges it says
starting in season 2 you will be able to
complete a mix of daily and weekly
challenges to level up your battle pass
if you miss a few weeks or start late no
worries your weekly challenges will
still be there and around for you when
you're returned and you can complete
them all at once while we do not want to
introduce wacky challenges that
drastically warp the way you played the
game these challenges should provide
some interesting variation from game to
game
this means all players should feel more
rapid battle Presta progression and then
the journey will hopefully be more fun
and interesting also this addition
should allow for players who are can
dedicate a few hours a week to the game
can make a very deep cut into their
battle past progression and not be left
behind it while the other players grind
their hearts out the legendary items
they're going to be adding a lot more to
the battle past there will be a
legendary item every 25 levels in the
premium track that means including at
the purchase of level 1 25 50 75 and 100
you will be getting a legendary
item our goal is to have a nice balance
of cool character exclusive and
cosmetics for everyone like weapon skins
the level hundred reward will be an
evolving weapon skin it with a special
recolor version for the players who make
it to level 110 this is very similar to
the current one we have the apex of the
in the apex season one battle pass the
current one is a half expand which
really isn't my favorite I'm not really
a big fan on the havoc I've more
prefered the devotion in this case so
hopefully when they do do a weapon like
that it is going to be the are 99 are
301 the wingmen the very popular ones
that people actually have a reason to
use these and kind of show it off in
game when you pick up the weapon as well
they talked about the battle pass badges
and the stat track being removed
completely from the battle pass Awards
in season two you're still going to be
getting a seasonal badge but it'll be a
single evolving badge that won't take up
any additional reward slots we kept the
seasonal wind trackers in the free path
and they will be earn about the first
ten levels so you can get the stat
tracks very early on in the game if you
do want those that are those are going
to be completely free they didn't want
they wanted to do that in the free
section as to not take up space in the
paid section so that we can actually get
a lot more stuff like legendary skins
and stuff that's actually useful and
that should belong in the paid category
and also they're going to be replacing
the voice lines with crafting metal
rewards you'll be able to earn enough
crafting metals about 1200 to craft a
legendary item of your choosing so if
there's an existing item you've been
coveting you'll be able to get it in
season 2 you can still get additional
crafting metals from the apex awards and
the battle paths as well but this is
just to help the players that really
want to get a legendary skin but don't
have the money to grind for apex packs
or have the time to get those as well
and as a sending off they said we have a
lot more to tell you about what you can
expect in season 2 so make sure to tune
in to our live stream on Saturday June
8th see her what we have in store and
that was basically the huge quick recap
let me know what you guys think I'm
super excited for season 2 they haven't
shown us anything about the character
and do not worry of course I will cover
the backstory of that character give us
a little bit of lore on what this
character is gonna be a lot of people
have been speculating that it will be
Watson who is the one character that was
recently shown leaked about right after
octane release so it's gonna be exciting
if that is him judging based off of what
the leaks are and if it's true
that'd be really cool he's got like some
electric-fence defensive type characters
that we also really nice to see and how
he kind of fits into the apex world
yeah but of course like I stated before
we got new legendaries come into the
battle past the stat tracks the voice
trackers and all that useless stuff is
gonna be out of the battle past some but
staying in the free section so that s to
not take up the paid section as well as
some new legend of the han skins that
are gonna be coming this season in
season one of apex legends and as well
of course like I said the new stuff in
season 2 so let me know all your
thoughts on that I would love to hear
everything you guys think about for
season 2 of apex legends do you think
it'll make a comeback with this season I
wouldn't really say a full comeback in
my opinion but at least get some of the
players like myself that haven't been
playing and maybe even you two that
haven't really been playing the past
couple weeks because there really isn't
much to do and I'm just been kind of
bored of the game it's the same
repetitive stuff all the time so I just
kind of need that fresh new content to
play and have a reason to grind for ya
as always like the VP - enjoy guys
subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of apex legends that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the pageant's of the leaks so if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
apex legends and never miss out on an
update that we stay subscribe to the
channel I also cover the lore of Apex
legend so if you want to know more about
the characters that we play as in-game
just def atleast a subscribe the channel
if you want more of a story aspect my
Twitter and discord will be in the
description down below and my two most
recent videos are gonna be popping a bun
screen you guys want to check that out
my Twitter and just score to be in the
description down below and my two most
recent videos are gonna be popping up on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out my guys so big race today thank you
for watching the video stay tuned on
Tuesday for more info about that legend
of the hunt stuff I can't wait to recap
that once I find out what more of that
is and take care guys enjoy the rest of
your day
[Music]